G
FIRE AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
STORM.
WE DID TALK TO THE OWNER.
THE HOUSE HAS BEEN IN THE
FAMILY FOR ABOUT 50 YEARS.
THE OWNER JUST INHERITED IT,
CAME BACK IN A TRIAL RENOVATE
THE HOUSE.
AND THEN THIS HAPPENS.
HE SAYS IT IS FULLY INSURED.
BUT AGAIN, HOW MUCH OF THIS IS
RECOVER BULL, THAT'S ANYONE'S
GUESS AT THIS POINT.
WE ALSO TRAVELED AROUND TO
OTHER AREAS AROUND ST.
PETERSBURG.
AND HERE IN THE TOWN OF LARGO,
WE WENT TO A NEIGHBORHOOD OF
MANUFACTURED HOMES, FOUND THE
ROOTS RIFT ALL OF TWO HOUSES.
SO, JUST FANNING OUT AND
GETTING A SENSE OF THE
DEVASTATION HERE IN THE ST.
PETERSBURG AREA.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
THAT KIND OF ASSESSMENT.
BRIAN TODD, CNN, LARGO,
FLORIDA.
♪ ♪ ♪
THE U.S. EMBASSY IN MOSCOW IS
URGING AMERICANS TO LEAVE
RUSSIA IMMEDIATELY, WHILE THEY
ARE STILL OPTIONS TO DO SO.
THE SECURITY ALERT COMES AFTER
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
ANNOUNCED THE PARTIAL
MOBILIZATION OF RUSSIAN MEN TO
FIGHT IN UKRAINE.
THE ALERT WARNS THAT RUSSIAN
AUTHORITIES HAVE ARRESTED U.S.
CITIZENS WHO HAVE PARTICIPATE
IN DEMONSTRATIONS, AND MAY
CONSCRIPT JUNE NATIONALS FOR
MILITARY SERVICE.
MEANTIME, THE LINES OF MANY
TRYING TO FLEE RUSSIA ARE GOING
BY THE DAY.
POLICE BORDER GUARD HAS SAID
50,000 RUSSIANS HAVE ENTERED
FINLAND SINCE THE PARTIAL MODEL
IS A SHUNT WAS ANNOUNCED A
WEEK.
A RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA WARNS
THAT DRAFT PAPERS WILL BE
HANDED TO ALL ELIGIBLE MEN
TRYING TO LEAVE RUSSIA FOR
GEORGIA.
CNN'S MELISSA BELL HAS THE.
DETAILS
TO THE SAFETY OF GEORGIA, THEY
HAVE WALKED.
OR CYCLED, CARRYING WHAT THEY
CAN IN THEIR TENS OF THOUSANDS.
NOT UKRAINIANS FLEEING THE WAR,
BUT RUSSIANS FLEE THE DRAFT.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> I CAME BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT, SAYS DANISH.
THE COUNTRY HAS NO PLAN, AND WE
CAN SEE THAT.
THE FEELING OF UNCERTAINTY IS
OUR BIGGEST FEAR.
DENNIS SAYS HE WALKED FOR SIX
DAYS TO GET TO THE LARS
CROSSING.
OTHERS ARE STUCK IN THEIR CARS
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THE LINE OF TRAFFIC AT A
VIRTUAL STANDSTILL, AND GETTING
LONGER EVERY DAY.
MANY ABANDONING THEIR CARS
ALTOGETHER.
LIKE THIS MAN, WHO WALKED THE
FINAL 20 KILOMETERS TO GET
ACROSS THE BORDER.
HE WILL NOT SHOW HIS FACE
BECAUSE OF THE WIFE AND THREE
CHILDREN HE HAD TO LEAVE
BEHIND.
THE WAR IN UKRAINE, HE SAYS, IS
NOT BLACK AND WHITE.
BUT THE DRAFT IS.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> IF IT DOES NOT CONCERN US
TODAY, IT WILL TOMORROW, HE
SAYS.
ON TV THEY TELL US THIS IS
BEING DONE TO DEFEND OUR
COUNTRY.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, IT TURNS
OUT, WE JUST GRAB SOMEBODY
ELSE'S LAND.
THEY ARE STUDENTS, MATT
FEATURES, MARKETING MANAGERS.
MANY OF THEM NOT EVEN ELIGIBLE
FOR THE DRAFT A 300,000 MEN
WITH MILITARY EXPERIENCE, BUT
FEARFUL OF WHERE IT WILL LEAD.